everybody who was involved in the in the
murder of ahmad arbury they're convicted
thank god man right thank you
absolutely if
this case specifically if they walked
away scratch free yeah hell oh
oh yeah i mean because again there was
video evidence this was really hard to
watch band imagine if there wasn't video
evidence oh yeah i see the same right
right where was this located at
oh [ __ ] i don't know man i can't
remember
atlanta atlanta it was in atlanta so a
mod arbory is jogging around in five
four
three
two one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the yeenus brain
podcast
he doesn't be good with this one
i was so confused man i was like
what are you talking about that's how
the uh the mexican fam here in l.a say
dodgers yeah but did you see uh so they
do latino night at uh the dodgers
stadium
and the teams wear like spanish names it
says
no that was a problem it says lost
dodgers and all the fans were like [ __ ]
that i don't want to buy that i want to
buy yours
so nobody bought those jerseys that's a
hell of fun
that's so [ __ ] funny man we um
i mean people did bring this up which i
thought was very interesting
was
sesame street has a korean character now
oh yeah yeah yeah and they like you know
try to make her seem just like a normal
type of girl you know i didn't know i
you know i never really thought about it
but i didn't realize sesame street had
races because people are orange and
yellow yeah they're like little monsters
right yeah so they they had brought on a
black uh muppet kid i believe oh latino
kid and now this is the first asian yeah
well she's like the simpsons right like
technically based on their skin color
they should be asian
and they i guess they're white yeah me
yeah exactly that's one of my favorite
episodes the funny thing
the funniest thing about asians on
simpsons though back in the day you know
they had different colors yeah asians
were white yeah that's right yeah like
that's sushi yeah yeah the sushi arts
karate teacher yeah
forgiveness
i wonder why i looked at that as a kid
and i didn't find that racist here's
here's the question i don't still find
it racist this is dr nick because dr
nick looks asian but his accent is not
eastern european type of [ __ ] i think so
i think it's supposed to be ambiguous
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but his last
name is riviera oh yeah so it might be
south american it's confusing man i
don't get it dude you know if you go
back and watch the first season oh bro
the animation style is so different but
smithers is black
wait what really yeah he was black get
the [ __ ] out of here
smithers yeah
i could have sworn i saw the entirety of
the first it wasn't just carl
wow carl was tight yeah
smithers was colorized in his first
appearance as a black dude with blue
hair wow
[Laughter]
yeah interview with tmz said that this
was a mistake but the producers didn't
have enough money to correct it
in many ways smithers represents the
stereotype of a closeted gay man yeah
that's crazy i didn't know that i didn't
know that smithers is gay i think lenny
and carl got together too
oh in the show yeah i believe so get the
[ __ ] out of here that's crazy but you
know what it's been so long ago that i
saw the first episode i'm probably just
not remember nobody watches that first
season yeah the drawing style was like
just horizontal like oh my goodness but
yeah i mean i i got a [ __ ] dm like
i posted about the korean muppet yeah i
mean that's pretty cool
and then but someone said like oh you
know race baiting something that has
nothing to do with race in the first
place
i'm like hey man
come on
that's just not where i'm called
it's a muppet she's seven years old
leave her alone
she also she has a korean ass name too
young you know what which means sesame
apparently right oh it does she only
says she's like yeah my name in korean
means sesame oh
it was so funny when i was um
i forgot who posted this but they were
talking about how in the episode she was
breaking down how korean people give uh
names and like the meaning of her name
right yeah what she means and young
means and she goes in korean something
something something and when you do it
this way that way and i was listening to
it i'm like hey no korean person doing
that there's not a single american that
knows what the [ __ ] she's talking about
my parents would not have told me that
yeah exactly
what it means because because of the
show there's some people wrote to me in
my dm's they're like oh what's your cra
i want to know what the meaning is i'm
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
no
[ __ ]
meaning of my [ __ ] yeah what's your name
peter
you know ask a fob yeah
i don't even think fox would know really
man no no i'm pretty sure fobs in korea
don't know this [ __ ] they're like my
name has a meanie yeah it's like you
know they're trying to be super
politically correct with yeah let's not
do that yeah you don't have to go that
far it's like what's your name my
parents gave me that name [ __ ]
sesame street [ __ ] what does it
mean i don't know what the [ __ ] it means
it's just my name
to me yeah asian boys for life
she starts gang banging and [ __ ]
that'd be [ __ ] tight i'm talking
about breaking stereotypes let's do it
again getting back
korean girl so this is what she says so
in korean traditionally the two
syllables they each mean something
different and chi means like smart or
wise and young means like brave or
courageous and strong
i'm like [ __ ] i know that
i had no [ __ ] i don't know what the
[ __ ] my name means that's for sure but
we were looking it up and guess what chi
also means sesame
she also means
you [ __ ] rape
yeah they're saying if you know what the
funny thing is when you you know
obviously twitter always you know tries
to put somebody on blast which there was
like people in politics talking about
how this is like an abomination to
america like it's becoming too racial
and
it's like it's [ __ ] sesame street bro
yeah yeah they they have you know like
you said the the black uh the the black
american muppet the mexican-american
muppet why can't we have an asian
hiv muppet get the [ __ ] out
that's hiv positive
that's hilarious yeah wow aren't they
supposed to be kids yeah so like
that's pretty careful you get that yeah
yeah that's that's pretty terrible i
mean the point being though like they
reach out through these muppets and then
these muppets according to whatever
ethnicity or
whatever it's going through yeah they
have an autistic muppet okay okay and so
they teach how yeah it works right and
like
um for you know one kid my parents get
divorced but then they'll do like
race-centric something they're going
through this world that needs to be
explained okay okay so i think they're
saying like
in light of all the
stop asian hate and all that stuff i
think they probably want to bring up
some story line like where mom gets
assaulted or some [ __ ] yeah that's my
that's my theory
so i see so the the the the hiv one is a
kid with uh so
it's called her name or him is kami kami
is a character on uh takalani sesame and
sesame square the respective south
african and nigerian versions of the
children's television program sesame
street so it is it's representative of
the issues that's happening within the
country yeah and so like you said with
the whole stop asian hate thing they
thought it'd be smart to bring on an
asian character which is dope i [ __ ]
with that for sure for sure i mean the
whole point of it is to educate right
it's just to educate people on things
that maybe they're not aware of or you
know just be let know let it be known
that there's differences between other
people i wonder why they chose a korean
girl
instead of a chinese kid i don't know
right no i don't know maybe is sesame
street allowed in china maybe they're
like
maybe probably not it's probably not
probably not so like i mean i could i
could see how it's going to help korean
kids because it's not like my parents
explained [ __ ] to me growing up
100 no you get more educated through tv
than through your parents like what
stoppage hey i don't know not happening
me
but you know what sesame street it's
forever tainted in my head with dave
chappelle's version of it remember
[Laughter]
that is basically their version of the
grouch that charlie murphy voices yes
this song is i don't understand i make
love to my head
that's like oh my gosh
you know what i was watching chappelle
show yeah and my harmony was was uh
staying at our house
and
so that parody of sesame street came up
how many thought it was sesame street
right that's hello and then that muppet
pulls his pants down and his dick comes
out right the disease
isn't that the one that where he has
like warts on
talking about his
narrow diseases in the muppet like yeah
yeah dude oh my god
i love watching wrestling and i'm like
my big like it owes me money
that's where i got that live from
my husband loved cops dude
she didn't even know the name of the
show it was just called cops she's
called the bad boys dude yeah it was
entertaining bro i
i watched it when i was a kid i don't
know why i just like this i just watched
it to see somebody escape i'm like bro
these guys are fast as [ __ ] man yeah
let me tell you something this is some
non-racial [ __ ] all the white people got
caught all the black people [ __ ]
dusted these [ __ ]
every time i saw one of the black homies
there i'm like you ain't gonna catch
this fool this full
[ __ ] gone bro so cops got off the air
right
um in light of
a lot of the racial unrest that was
happening okay and they said that it
wasn't helping the society
they took it off it's like wow that's
pretty commendable yeah yeah it's coming
back
so fox news has a streaming service now
right that's what they bought for right
of course they're airing it yeah all
these [ __ ] korean they're super happy
i was awaiting poor days
you know what's hilarious
cops originated in the neighborhood i
grew up in in washington oh for real
lakewood washington that's like the
korea town of that's crazy that's where
it originated from the first episode of
cops was is you could see like lakewood
washington
they still have a bunch of like i keep
seeing landmarks that actually yeah
right next to my church like yeah oh hey
look like oh i know that but it's not
fair every episode of cops i'm like
where is that in america
yeah the best show better than cops is
uh steven seagal dude him being a cop
this whole had a [ __ ] show where he
was a share no i don't know
he had a few seasons dude
i talked about this on the previous
podcast the funniest episode funniest
episodes is him trying to talk to any
black person
he likes code switches yeah he does like
he's
code switching when i first saw this
i was crying laughing it's like what you
trying to what you talking all that
nonsense
oh my god and it was switched to the
camera and he goes i'm trying to address
uh arrest this gentleman because he's
loitering and he's like once you get my
autograph i thought you said i was
fronting
like yo steven seagal get the [ __ ] out
of his level of delusion is out of this
world like this guy thinks he's a
[ __ ] supreme being a master of the
martial arts and turns out it's all lies
that's all lies
absolutely isn't that why he lives in
russia now does he oh because he still
celebrated that i have no
[ __ ] audience
and this guy like when he would do
movies i mean other actors are on record
of saying how like rough he was with him
like he would actually try to hurt them
yeah just to be like yeah that's what it
takes
what the [ __ ] i'm not a fighter bro i'm
an actor man do our buddy who does sound
that we all know he he actually worked
on a project that steven seagal was a
part of oh i would have loved to have
been upset so you want to hear the
funniest thing and i i told the story so
if you guys ever heard it i don't care
so that's a lot of people
so
he had to do uh adr for his own film
this is steven seagal's own film
he's starring in it he wrote it it stars
him
so stephen segal is apparently
notoriously known for not wanting to do
adr
even in his own [ __ ] film what's adr
adr is basically so you know uh when you
have audio and you don't catch it really
well yeah maybe it's raining or there's
a helicopter or you're on a bus or a car
you have to re-record the dialogue yes
you're gonna get like the ac or whatever
okay okay and so he had to do adr so
they had they brought him into the
studio to do it
apparently he only does one take and
that's funny
this is for his own movie so he comes in
super bad attitude whatever starts doing
it you know does it in steven seagal
fashion does a [ __ ] terrible job
they're like hey steven we need to do
this again he goes i only do one take
leaves
this is his film by the way this is
something that he's hired for this is
out of his own budget i think this film
is on netflix
so
they decide that the only option that
they have
is to get um
a uh
voice impersonator to come in to
impersonate stephen
for the adr stuff right oh man the guy
comes in and [ __ ] kills it
so i guess the person who was uh dealing
with the adr sub wasn't the director it
was
probably the assistant director or
whatever right
he comes in and listens to it over again
he goes you need to [ __ ] trash this
and they say why he goes because this
person speaks way too clear
they need to mumble their words this job
is too good
so they had the impersonator come in and
then [ __ ] up the lions and start
mumbling yeah and they use that instead
of the original wow man
it was too good dude the voice
impersonator was completely going on a
limit guessing but just how ridiculous
he is i was like it would make sense
that they would hire a voice
impersonator to do that he's hilarious
man the way he talks about himself
specifically with mma fighters yeah he
takes credit for all these women he said
he takes credit for anderson the [ __ ]
the front kick
which is hilarious because he's an akito
master they don't even have a [ __ ]
fun kick dude
so for people who don't know like in
aikido is actually a legitimate martial
arts right depending but the martial art
was created to disarm people with swords
that's why you see a lot of wrist grabs
wrist locks flips and toss so it was
made to disarm somebody who has a weapon
and you don't have a weapon and that was
the purpose of aikido and he is actually
a legit aikido master and i think he's
one of the uh he was the first american
to be able to open up an aikido dojo in
the states right so he's legit in that
sense
the [ __ ] front kick [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you know like anderson silva is
super respectful yeah so yeah he's kind
of he's like there's an interview with
him talking about listen um i don't i
don't want my children to fight i don't
know who i want to win they're both my
kids they're both my sons oh my god
get the [ __ ] out of here guys this guy
is he's he's a cuckoo in the head man
he's a giant he's like six five yeah
[Laughter]
oh my goodness he's so [ __ ] hilarious
yeah he's literally one of the most like
ridiculous hilarious to us but he
doesn't find himself hilarious he takes
himself so seriously
he's such a dirt bag yeah yeah there's
like so much [ __ ] going on like we were
i was saying this earlier because i'm
making this podcast once a week next
year but there's so much [ __ ]
what in the heck this podcast is brought
to you by purple my friends it's so damn
funny there are all these gimmicks that
promise a great night's sleep and i
don't care what kind of toppers there
are how heavy a blanket may be it's
lipstick on a freaking ugly pig if
you're sleeping on a terrible mattress
your sleep will be terrible it's that
simple i don't think any of you
understand how much time we spend
sleeping and if we're going to spend our
whole life sleeping you might as well do
it in pleasure and comfort sometimes i
would trade my own fiance for my purple
mattress
burial if you're listening to this i'm
sorry but the way that this mattress
comforts me and then fills all my nooks
and crannies pause never mind let's move
on the gel flex grid is amazingly
supportive for your back and legs while
cushioning your shoulders necks and hips
no matter how you sleep my friends
purple is amazing and i don't sleeps
without it and you're sleeping without
your purple well my friends don't know
how you're doing it because you're not
getting the sleep that i am getting a
great night's sleep starts with having a
great mattress get a purple mattress go
to purple.com
brain10 and use code brain 10 for a
limited time you can get 10 off any
order of 200 or more that's purple.com
brain10 codebrain10 for 10 percent off
any order of 200 or more purple.com
brain10 promo code breakden
to talk about because of what's
happening in this world is so [ __ ]
nuts like we just mentioned this i don't
know what there's that we have much to
say about this but there was a clip of
this girl who was a front woman in a
band that
literally pissed in this dude's mouth i
don't even know what the context for
this is man it was at a rock show and
she's one of the front women yeah by the
way
when this clip was sent to me and of
course khalif sent it to me
police sent me this clip i don't know
what i'm looking at you see this guy
being brought up on stage larger fellow
yeah he's laying down yeah the girl's
doing her [ __ ] on the mic and you see
her standing over him but i'm like oh
she's the thing that i thought was gonna
happen was that she was gonna allow the
guy to eat her out i'm like damn this is
already [ __ ] crazy yeah but she bends
over squats and starts pissing in this
dude's mouth okay was he given
instruction to lay down or he just got
up and laid by the way when he was
laying down yeah he loved it oh my
my question is was this requested by him
or was this offered by
the the front singer by the way when i
say piss yeah i'm not talking about a
stream yeah i'm talking about that
yeah
and she probably held in her piss for a
solid six weeks oh my god and just the
amount of liquid that came out of her
was insane wow he obliterated he got
obliterated huh
it was a tsunami but the dab was broken
the levy was broken dude and [ __ ]
unloaded on him and i'm just thinking
like dude
is this how shows are nowadays but but
look look
to be fair there are people with pissed
fetishes you know
maybe he that's exactly what he wanted
and he got his wildest dream fulfilled
it just happened in a public forum
apparently she made a public apology but
in my opinion you have nothing to
apologize for like everybody knows your
band's name now yeah well except for us
know who did if he liked it yeah what
you apologizing for
you made his day yeah i thought there
were laws against that i was also saying
like damn we thought like someone like
marilyn manson would have done that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] public urination is
technically illegal right or is that
different in certain parts of the
country i feel like anything goes on a
[ __ ] show dude
would that be considered public though
or private it is public right it is
public a lot of a lot of rock stars got
in trouble for public indeed decency for
the [ __ ] they do on stage yeah right so
i mean i don't understand what
that would fall under i i guess we just
live in a new age man yeah this is it
it's just a future
you can pee on somebody on camera and
it's all cool now i feel like kelly is
not guilty
that's what i'm talking about
that's what i've been about he's in jail
right now he goes oh so it's okay for
her that's why
the craziest thing man you know
especially because
every time i hear the concert thing so
we you know we covered a little bit of
the the thing that happened in uh astral
world with travis scott
which was [ __ ] crazy man oh you guys
talked about that well we talked about
it i mean but we could talk about i
didn't talk about it in great detail
though i didn't know anything that
happened i know a little side story
about it that i saw there was a so i
follow uh fight porn on reddit it's a
subreddit of just straight fights right
at that same astro world uh concert
uh there's this clip where uh there's
this
long like lanky white dude with a cup of
beer or some [ __ ] right there's a group
of asian kids
right at the back of this and there's
just like this open pit
and um
he's talking [ __ ] to them and then
they're just like whatever like ignoring
him so he throws his drink in there and
it lands on them right
and so these asian kids turn around and
one of them because all right that's it
and then his friend's helping him take
off his
earrings and [ __ ] and then this dude
takes off his baggy sweatshirt and he's
[ __ ] ripped
oh my god the asian dude just comes at
it and throws a forearm to the face yeah
but not only that then a gang of 20
other asian kids
jumping this white dude
[Music]
dude that's such an anime moment i know
that's how hello funny let me show you
how i get super safe
right like he's like [ __ ] with this
dude that they think is a wimp and he
takes off his shirt and he's ripped yeah
yeah really cause then somebody threw
that drink i took off my shirt they're
like that makes sense
and they they would just be shocked that
this fat guy beat the [ __ ] that's all
right majin buu had straight yeah
that's what i'm saying though
that's hella funny i wonder if that's
one of those like this is the moment
that i [ __ ] up yeah
it was at this moment it was that's the
moment that he really asian people fight
back dude and we're fighting [ __ ] big
ass numbers dude so yeah other news
about that though um
drake and
um travis scott they're getting sued for
two billion dollars holy [ __ ] why drake
drake's part of astroworld he was it was
he went up there and was performing
while people were dying too oh my god
yeah i mean it's kind of crazy too right
um
because obviously when we talked about
asteroid we don't know too much about it
right i just i also i in the podcast i
talked about how there was a certain
point where there was a girl who was
recounting what happened there and long
story short with that she said that she
it was pandemonium it was [ __ ] nuts
yeah people were being squeezed so hard
that they were it was like a pimple like
people were popping up because that's
how hard they were being
squeezing
i forget what that thing is called when
the crowd is moving and you you are
forcibly moved with that movement yeah
but people you know talking about that
sensation say it's the strangest thing
because you start to feel pressure you
can't move and in some instances their
feet is off the ground yeah and then
they are moving along you know and so
um this girl talked about how when she
fell over she saw somebody's face right
under her yes oh my god these people are
getting trampled and then she says she
saw another person under that person
how oh my god [ __ ] crazy yeah right i
mean but look man this guy travis scott
he's a [ __ ] he's garbage man like if
you see
in in uh like one of his previous
concerts too like he's crowd surfing i
don't know if you guys addressed this
part i saw this yeah
so
he's crowd surfing and one of his fans
tried to steal his shoes right now of
course that's that's an offense and he
should be kicked out of the concert
promptly right but this guy travis grabs
a mic he spits on him and said he starts
yelling [ __ ] him up [ __ ] him like he's
encouraging his fans to basically beat
this guy
that guy right there get him get that
guy get that and he's like yelling [ __ ]
him up [ __ ] him up like he's chanting to
himself to get the crowd into it like
i'm sorry bro like you don't have enough
money to get some news exactly so i mean
i think that kind of shows you what type
of person this guy is i don't know him
personally so i can't say but like that
you know i'm sure it's not the first
time that that's happened in a crowd uh
surfing moment where somebody tried to
steal something from the artist but the
reaction wasn't [ __ ] him up you know
yeah and in this case with the
astroworld yeah he just did not give a
[ __ ] of what was happening and he's
known to he's been charged with inciting
a riot yeah yeah yeah
see this is all these details i didn't
invite yeah man
and so he just went along with the
concert like nothing's happening i kind
of did laugh though people were a little
upset because i was giggling a little
bit about this part about people are
literally dying and this was doing the
robot oh i saw that video like
it's like when it comes to
when it comes to like trauma and [ __ ]
like this stuff yeah
i can't help but laugh because that's
the only thing i can do right
and this guy's like
yeah it's just ridiculous you can't help
me yeah like the emt is like doing cpr
and the camera shifts to travis cut and
he's like
it's so ridiculous you can't help but
[ __ ] laugh because it's just like
this is not real this that can't be
happening man this is the thing you
think in defense because uh i guess like
if i'm you know i'm always trying to
think about the other side too it's like
it's kind of hard to say now now that i
know the the the details because there
were clips of him saying like everybody
move out the way but that's kind of
after the fact how much pandemonium it
was way after yeah it was way out and
also too it's like well you know you see
this crowd of people out there how is he
supposed to know but it showed that he
did know and he didn't care
so you know when celebrities kind of go
out and they he put the he's like i'm he
puts out this puppy oh that [ __ ]
apology was garbage first of all i don't
understand why celebrities do public
apologies when clearly it shows that
they don't give a [ __ ]
like come on
think take a second it's like bro come
on listen if kyle roonhouse can cry
you know maybe i could you know yeah but
yeah i saw that i'm like this doesn't
look good it doesn't come across genuine
at all you know it seemed like his
lawyer trained him on what to say and he
was trying to [ __ ] remember what to
say while giving the apology yeah you
know and it's like okay i got to make
sure i i cover all the points and
protect myself so that i you know i'm
not legally liable for
because he what is the stuff that he
said that he was going to do he was
going to pay for the funeral costs for
the people who died
and do something else with the two it's
like
i don't know man i i i watched maybe
about like a minute into that apology
and i was like this is [ __ ] garbage i
was like i'm not i'm not going to give
him any more sex damn too much because
wait this was also a live nation thing
right so are they suing travis scott and
drake and not going at the live nation
that i don't know
yeah i have no idea yeah yeah that's
very interesting because i would think
that they would go for live nation
because it seems to be bigger but i
guess it's it's part of him and his
control over this like like i said like
um
there were complaints about the lack of
security to save on their costs you know
so those weak ass fences but the
organization was very poorly done yeah
that's for sure something like this
doesn't happen in a well-organized
concert he was known to just tell us
fans yeah break in to get up front yeah
you know like rush home rush this year
yeah the weird thing is too when i see
that concert um there was like there
were people who were trying to bash
travis scott everyone said i'm not on
travis scott's side or anything
people are like yeah you know me and my
me and my seven-year-old almost died
it's like i'm sorry
worst parent on [ __ ] earth you
brought your [ __ ] seven-year-old to a
[ __ ] travis scott concert you piece
of [ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing
my children were endangered they should
not be at a travis scott concert what
are you talking about yeah that's that's
more judgment but you know hey not
everybody is a good parent
and they were talking about my 14 year
old kid could have died you let your 14
year old child go to a travis concert
unsupervised
what is this like what is going on and
they're trying to make write these posts
as if they're dignified in this response
it's like you shouldn't have written
that because it shows how shitty of a
[ __ ] parent you are too well okay
with the the teenager get going to the
concert maybe the parent didn't know we
could say that give them the benefit of
the doubt they didn't know who travis
scott was because his name is travis
scott but taking your seven-year-old
yourself
that's clearly
uh you you kind of [ __ ] up there bro
yeah
that's perfectly fine man with a name
like that he must be okay his first name
is justice
so in other news um this is very
interesting so we uh just talked about
in the previous podcast
about the whole carl rittenhouse thing
in some positive news for a lot of
people um a mod arbory
um everybody who was involved in the in
the murder of ahmad arbury
they're convicted thank god man right
thanks
absolutely if this case specifically if
they walked away scratch-free yeah hell
well
oh yeah
i mean because again there was video
evidence this was really hard to watch
band imagine if there wasn't video
evidence oh yeah i see the same right
right where was this located at this
podcast is brought to you by skillshare
my friends every human was born to
create whether you last picked up a
paintbrush yesterday or in grade school
you can explore your creativity and be
inspired my friends
if you haven't known already skillshare
is a long time sponsor skillshare is
something that i use and i've told you
many times before i am still going over
this course with
mkbhd that's marcus brownlee himself
youtube success script shoot and edit
because it's going to help me brush up
for next year when i start doing youtube
videos again and it's always great to
learn from people at the top of their
game even though i've done it i have so
much more to learn my friends skillshare
has an entire catalog of classes and now
offer subtitles in spanish french
portuguese and dutch as well my friends
so fret not you can always get the
classes you need and the information the
way you want to learn it and your time
and guess what my friends it's also
incredibly affordable an annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month so explore your creativity at
skillshare.com brain and get a one month
free trial of premium membership that's
one month of a premium membership at
skillshare.com brain
oh [ __ ] i don't know man i can't
remember but atlanta atlanta it was in
atlanta so a mod arbory is jogging
around in a neighborhood
uh these men uh basically hunt him down
like a [ __ ] animal dude
this that was super hard to watch like
in the back of a pickup truck chasing
him down he was he was jogging or was
just walking
jogging he was working out he's part of
a sports team right and so he was um
looking at a construction site right
yeah i do that all the time i do it all
the [ __ ] time like what's being built
here
yeah you know if you're black you're
guilty of doing something you know what
i mean blows my mind and they're like
well he was reaching for our shotgun
he's like you chased him down with your
truck and you cornered him yeah yeah
like you're clear you were clearly after
him this man was fearing for his life
yeah and he was doing whatever he can to
try to protect himself dude that video
was hard to watch yeah dude because he
got shot in the chest point blank with a
[ __ ] by a shotgun right yeah
dude this [ __ ] white vigilantism like
never ever ends up good yeah i know
always some [ __ ] i don't know can
they not see that by now because the the
thing that what what was like the the
dirty [ __ ] was
those
it was two men or three three three but
they were connected to the sheriff of
something like that or he used to be a
part of law enforcement or something as
well
i think that the father
yeah something like that i can't
remember exactly what the connection was
but dude the defense and i i just saw
this because ed told me to watch this
clip
it's terrible and [ __ ] hilarious yeah
yeah the audacity the audacity to talk
about a mod arbor is [ __ ] toenails as
if that's a reason for why he was seen
as a criminal relevancy what is the
relevance of this guy's dirty toenails
yeah literally i'm i'm sure if that was
part of the evidence they looked at like
they took off his socks in an autopsy oh
my god look at his nails my god he's a
criminal he's a criminal he's black and
he has dirty toners that's essential if
it had to have any connection she should
have said the autopsy
obviously says this guy has some nasty
ass toenails yeah like and that proves
he's a criminal that's essentially what
i can only take away from bro when i was
watching the [ __ ] closing argument i
was like holy [ __ ] i cannot believe what
i'm hearing right now
this lady is trying to first of all
target the heartstrings of of the jury
you know
she goes into saying [ __ ] like this i
was like [ __ ] are you [ __ ] of sound
mind you know
you're a lawyer i've never seen an
innocent person with dirty ass toenails
i mean it was also the fact that she
mentioned his socks covering his dirty
toys yo why the [ __ ] do we wear socks
yeah yeah
i'm sorry
was he supposed to be sockless yeah and
have absolutely impeccable toenails
where i grew up everybody had nice
toenails and in fact in deuteronomy
thou shall not have
unpedicured fight and if you do that's
the foot of a sinner which means clearly
he was out there robbing the whites
crazy to be stoned in the first phase
hilarious
what is going on like that's just the
funniest thing i've ever seen in my life
yeah and what did she think that she was
i bet you when she wrote that [ __ ] out
she's like this is going to get them
yeah
you know you know the thing is i
actually didn't watch the prosecution's
closing arguments because i saw that and
i was like it was like there's no way
i'm like come on if
oh my lord dude it would have been the
most insane [ __ ] thing ever dude i i
just can't
help but laugh yeah that is hilarious
again another one of those things where
it's so ridiculous that you can't help
but laugh you're just so appalled and
you're just like so dumbfounded like
are those really the words that are
coming out of your mouth right now if i
was there and i was those three guys
that were being prosecuted i just what
the [ __ ]
are you doing that's that that that was
their expression actually if when you
see that closing argument and the camera
is showing those guys they look
concerned you know
like oh boy can i just tell y'all
something from multiple people's
accounts i heard that a mod arbory
farted a lot yeah
and what kind of good man farts and
looks at construction sites yeah man
he's a serial farter everybody
it's like a [ __ ] clown i'm i'm glad
justice was served in that case as well
you know because
yeah the dude was straight murdered you
know what i mean like in cold blood man
like
that like you said he got hunted down
like an animal yeah you know like he was
some sort of [ __ ] game
it looked very it
like replaced those cars with horses
and whips and that's what it looked like
to me it looked ridiculous yeah i
couldn't believe what i was [ __ ]
seeing yeah and they were doing that in
in guys of justice like yeah they
thought it was their right to to you
know make a citizen's arrest that it was
their god-given duty to to do that oh my
god
oh my god it's the
entitlement i've been seeing a lot that
i grew up with i mean
it's
it hits a sore spot for me because i
grew up in the [ __ ] sticks yeah right
of people like that
who
won't necessarily like you for being
some anywhere at any place anytime
and
they'll see you and feel like they have
the right which they do i guess but then
they just come up to you and they just
start talking [ __ ] to you like
what and i'm just sitting there like
what did i do to you well like why are
you having such a bad day because you're
in in you in their eyes you along with
other minorities are subhuman yeah
you're not on their level of humanity
you know
no i mean like the the kind of [ __ ] i'd
go through
over
doom [ __ ] of of some guy trying to make
justice out of some form or doing
something weird right yeah like i was
driving down the street and it was a
school zone and apparently i was going
too fast well i literally wasn't paying
attention i was just headed to the weed
store
well this [ __ ] guy
followed me
all the way to the weed store and comes
out there and then he goes do you know
how fast you're going
and i'm like wait are you cops and it's
like clearly not you're driving this
beat-up pickup truck
and i'm like
um i don't know i don't know he's like
you know if you drive that fast the cops
will come here and beat your ass
and i'm like
i i was speechless yeah for a moment
like after he left i was like i should
have [ __ ] them up
you know like
like i was literally like wait who the
[ __ ] was he like was he the cops what
the [ __ ]
like
that that like what gives you the right
yeah the pyongshin batman [ __ ] i keep
talking about these people who feel like
they
they're being an upright citizen he's
gonna go home to his dinner table i told
some asian guy also well yeah because
they but literally it's this idea of
like
i'm a true american so i need to teach
this foreigner what it's like to live in
this country
that's what i'm saying and we have this
conversation multiple times about
a lot of people don't understand what
it's like to be in this country and
still feel like you don't belong even
though you're just as american as a
person who doesn't look like you and
that's what that is it's that level of
entitlement of he's trying to teach you
how to be a real person in this country
it's like what gives you the right what
are you talking about guys i can't tell
you how many times people told me to go
back to my own country and i'm like i
was born here where they say [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you don't even speak english i'm
speaking english to you right now yeah
but you got an accent yeah you got an
accent i'm speaking yeah
dude i've gotten that too i got in the
face of some [ __ ] pyongshin
[ __ ] starting [ __ ] with me in my
store like harassing this breast cancer
survivor she has [ __ ] tubes and she
has a [ __ ] oxygen tank this
motherfucker's giving her [ __ ] and then
i'm like yo you can't do that you're
gonna get the [ __ ] out of here yeah and
then his he dropped his [ __ ] on the
floor like was technically my [ __ ] he
didn't pay for it right you know you
just threw it on the ground and then i
just got a kind of guy in his face i'm
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you
need to apologize to her right [ __ ]
now what the [ __ ] is the matter with you
and he goes
first
he says oh wow
you don't have an accent
oh my god and he's like you speak pretty
good english and i said [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yeah
yeah he was like you don't know [ __ ]
[ __ ] about me or whatever and he's like
oh man your dad would be proud of you oh
that's right he's dead
and he went personal and i was like
like if i [ __ ] him up right now my mom
will lose this door yeah yeah yeah and i
was like just get out get the [ __ ] out
of here you know and then this poor lady
is scared to death
and and i was like i'm sorry ma'am and
then you know i excorted her out
and took her to her car and this guy was
still sticking around
and he's done and i was like get the
[ __ ] out of her before i [ __ ] you up
he's like hit me bro i'll sue you for
everything you got that store is going
and i was like that's why you're a
[ __ ] coward yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ]
look at you you little [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
fat [ __ ]
slabby piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
scaring old one does that make you feel
like a [ __ ] i couldn't stop talking [ __ ]
yeah i just kept going yeah and then he
was like yeah that's all you're a coward
you're a coward and you
walked away on this [ __ ] bike
yeah and so i'm just like what the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] so
i went back through my video camera
to see what happened obviously i didn't
get on any audio but i put his picture
up
on our screen and i just put it on there
you know and people just keep asking who
is this guy you know what what happened
you know and i tell him exactly what
happened i said if you know this guy is
he's a piece of [ __ ] that's all i want
you to know i'm putting this up here
because he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah that's
it right
and then one guy comes in right
and then he goes
oh god
that's my son what did he do oh my god
dude
i told him i told him what was i told
him everything yeah and i was like and
he mentioned my dad yeah my dead dad
yeah and i was like i would never have
said anything about his father and i
don't even [ __ ] know him yes you yeah
i didn't say [ __ ]
you know and then and then he was like
i'm so he was embarrassed i'm so i'm so
sorry i'm sorry and then he left like a
five dollar bill and left but he didn't
buy anything
i hope this makes you feel better yeah
that's what i'm saying like i had to
i like
where the [ __ ] they think they're doing
they think they're the good guys right i
swear to god right no for sure for sure
they do they don't think they're in the
wrong when they're doing this [ __ ]
saying like they're sitting there i i'm
betting even for these people like i
don't personally know i'm making
assumptions right now but i bet you in
their mind they're like what did i do
wrong
like i'm in the right i'm the i'm the
just one and i'm sitting here being
prosecuted i feel like they can't even
wrap their head around what mistake that
they've made or even a mistake or
judgment called i thought
why are you treating me like a black man
[Laughter]
that'd be so funny that's exactly right
so after the the [ __ ] january 6 uh
riots and insurrection yeah a bunch of
people were trying to get on planes to
go back home and the the [ __ ] secret
service and like these the police caught
them right
one guy is he's being arrested he's like
what'd i do what i do why are you
treating me like a black man and they're
like that's it
there it is
yeah you get it so when people say that
too like okay that's a literal account
of it right and they're acting as if
racism in this country doesn't exist now
here's the thing
has it gotten better of course right i
think as time has shown we can't say
that it hasn't gotten better in terms of
metrics right like
like there's no slavery anymore and
there's no like real public like actual
lynching on a [ __ ] tree yeah we can
say that but we can also say that
there's still a lot of room for
improvement and there's still heavy
remnants of racism still here even
though it's not written in law the
people who still believe it they still
enact upon their racism and it's it's
institutional oh it's deep-rooted
deep-rooted americans that's the problem
though so white people don't know the
difference of what you were just saying
yeah right they think racism is slavery
they think racism is open lynching they
don't think
like
what the [ __ ] is happening today is
racism all right let's be spare some
white people
sorry i had to go through therapy for my
generalization for white people no i
mean you've clearly been through a lot
of [ __ ] and the restraint you showed in
some of these situations hey props to
you man because i think i think you
[ __ ] murk somebody for sure for damn
sure man if they're coming at me like
that it's like
all right man i'm going to jail tonight
yeah dude i made up my mind man yeah if
somebody talked about my dead dad i
think i'd probably find where he lived
[ __ ] slit his [ __ ] throat i would
start plotting i would start plotting
man but that [ __ ] doesn't never
came by her story again but uh my friend
owned this store down the street
and then i saw him there and i was
visiting him that day and he got the
[ __ ] out real quick so it's like oh at
the end of the day you're [ __ ]
embarrassed yeah you are a coward you
don't even like looking at me you [ __ ]
i wonder if he i wonder if his dad
spanked him oh no i brought i brought
him i purchased that beat his ass i
probably would guess that he got a
weapon with his belt
he probably think that built off cause
i'm gonna beat you like you're a black
man
yeah
i give it to like here's the thing like
there are like
hard-working men that just have to do
what the [ __ ] they have to do to survive
right
um the the [ __ ] people who work
lumber you know and dude
i i made friends with some of these
neighborhood kids and they just grew up
there in that area and that's what they
do they cut down timber you know and one
guy fell 50 [ __ ] feet off of a tree
broke his legs you know in his back
and
like a few months later i saw him
rolling in on a wheelchair
happy as [ __ ] you know he's alive kind
of thing damn they're and he went back
to where he's still working timber
you know and uh the regular police
officers that came through that just
live in the area and whatever like we
all respected each other the problem i
literally had
were with
i don't know if i want to go into some
franchise
yeah who looked at me and straight up
i'm behind the counter they're like look
at you you loser yeah what do you make
minimum wage you can't get a better job
than this you [ __ ] loser and i'm like
and they walk what did i do to you bro
well you know it's true though like
you know
hurt people always want other people to
hurt you know i think that the the hard
part is is that we're always taught to
like give empathy to people but empathy
runs out real fast especially when you
kind of overstep your boundaries like
that it's like having even like in
personal relationships like
i can only go so far as to say like oh
this person has treated me like [ __ ] or
has done something bad to me because of
their past life that still has a limit
it doesn't mean that i'm not going to
slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you if you
do something bad to me
right it doesn't excuse you from it
right it's just empathy can only go so
far sometimes it's very hard because i
try to be as empathetic as possible but
now i just tend to just cut people out
of my life it's like oh you're not a
good person
and i'm going to cut you out and it
makes me feel better now yeah but
obviously your sister you can't just cut
these people out i can't or yeah or yeah
in your case that's that was your
everyday so scenario but but to your
point of like cutting certain people out
it doesn't even have to go as far as a
judgment of you're not a good person
it's just i don't want to be around this
i don't want to be around you know what
you say and what you do
so i don't need to be a part of you know
you don't need to be a part of my life
anymore to speak on that man you know
that i have the video series of that guy
who always throws his money at me yeah
yeah right
and i i had it one day and i complained
yeah i was like oh my i'm going to blow
up at this [ __ ] guy you know this
like drives me crazy yeah yeah you know
and she was like think about it he comes
here every day and buys a 12 pack how
much does 12 pack cost
how many times a day does he come here
you know it's like do the math yeah and
i was like all right
he clearly like she likes us enough to
buy beer yeah so it's like don't put him
away then that's that's then we lose
that business though yeah that and
that's how to swallow that's the hard
part exactly that's the word man you got
to swallow that because it's your
business and your livelihood depends on
it so you have to
take that type of behavior and that type
of i you know maybe
you won't say it's as far as like it's
he's a racist but prejudice you know
i i could say you know amongst everybody
like yeah because there's it's it's so
hard to now like um very pinpoint you
want to say something is racist but
it's not
i would say an implicit bias yeah just
yes
they don't know that they've been
indoctrinated that they don't know they
grew up into that they don't realize
that is in them so nobody wants to say
yes i have racist tendencies nobody
wants to say that yeah i can be a little
racist i acknowledge that because i also
believe everyone everyone can be a
little racist yeah but white people
racist is the n word to them that's what
i realize if you call a white person
racist what that is not who i am like
of course right if you would only open
your eyes china
[Applause]
i got bigger eyes than you man
no but like they just they just
don't want to be called a racist and if
i say racist like
they
like white people really
really they get so incensed like they
don't want to be
called that at all yeah and i think it
goes to your point of saying it's like
their version of what racism is is them
not killing you yeah you know
that's like you know for these certain
type of white people it's like listen
i'm not over here [ __ ] burning the
cross on your lounge [ __ ]
it's like
yo a guy i i went to high school with
and this was like on facebook where he
was talking some [ __ ] on some blm stuff
right or on white privilege
and i was like bro i went to high school
with you you we've had many classes
you know
how i was treated because this
[ __ ] called me kenny wu from
mighty ducks
and i was like
you know you weren't treated the way i
was yeah because you're white yeah you
know yeah and i was like and
on the other side i still experience
this to this day people act like you
in high school
but they're grown as people and they
still behave this way to me you know for
sure you want to tell me there's no
white privilege absolutely you know what
he says
he says you should be thankful that you
have a business out here that's crazy
i'm like so that's not racist exactly
you're pre you're privileged
me allowing you to live your privilege
me allowing you to just exist the way
you are is a privilege right because you
[ __ ]
are subject
also too it's like you allow me who are
you who are you yeah you piece of [ __ ]
why do you allow me but that's the thing
that's that's what he's alluding to with
the whole elitist mindset you know just
this kind of like
it's the white american privilege yeah
man and and look i've said this before
too the most amount of racism that i
faced in my life were from white people
you know and and i'm not gonna lie there
was a period
especially when i was younger like my
elementary days i despised white people
because of it but then once i met other
white people who weren't like that
it was a learning experience for me like
oh okay no so i've told this when i
first came on this podcast app how i had
to go to therapy because of my major
generalization of white people and i was
i saw it in myself i said it out loud to
myself oh [ __ ] i'm being racist towards
white people because when i see a bald
white man with a goatee i'm [ __ ]
triggered
i
love him right yeah i would never want
to meet him for some reason no i got
this weird trigger to me anybody with
knee braces freaking me out dude
when i see him like i always feel like
oh [ __ ] like if i see a middle-aged
white guy yeah i get on my toes so i had
to go through therapy for that [ __ ] you
know to be like not everyone is the
enemy so that's why i hang out with dan
what's right
i mean he's so korean
the equalizer yeah that looks white as
[ __ ] yeah my therapist was like you
you have to meet good white people for
sure because she was like i know that's
hard to come by yeah it's like have you
and you're in you're in thanks for
acknowledging that yeah in your area
he speaks mandarin
[Music]
the worst manner i've ever heard in my
life well speaking of mandarin it was
segue into that uh wait what the [ __ ]
were you talking about that what was
that yeah so about china so uh this
renowned tennis player tennis champion
um that's not only known in the chinese
community but in the tennis community
right because she's a
tennis champion peng shui is her name
now she came out and um
made allegations about a chinese
government official
about sexual abuse uh-oh that she was
sexually abused by this person and you
know they used their power against her
and now she's dead oh no she disappeared
she yeah she got disappeared
real quick by the ccp oh she [ __ ] j
jack modder asked yeah they jack martyr
ass not only made her disappear
physically
any search result for her name came up
in zero in the chinese search engine
like she didn't exist yeah they made her
disappear bro
and then other
international communities the tennis
community started catching wind of like
where is she she's been missing right
and after about two weeks of being
missing it like that issue started
coming to the forefront of like the news
and stuff and it was like trending on
twitter whatever right
and then it's like well clearly
it's the [ __ ] ccp
you know that
they have a history of doing this [ __ ]
and you attack a government official in
the chinese communist party
it doesn't matter who you are jack ma is
the living proof of that now here's the
[ __ ] kicker
the foreign ministry
was asked about this and some i forget
what the the situation was but he was
asked about this because you know the
news was there and his response pretty
much i mean it's it's his i'm uh you
know kind of paraphrasing here but he
was just kind of like um i wasn't aware
of this person's disappearance
and even so
this is none of your business oh
my god this is not this is not a foreign
issue
i was like technically you're right
it's not a foreign issue that's crazy i
gotta respect the gangster bro it's like
damn
basically like what happened to it none
of your business yeah
would you come in here do i come into
your house and take a poop
this is not a foreign matter you know i
was like god
now here's the thing
she showed up um i think about three
days ago four days ago after being
missing for about like over two weeks
but you know how she showed up
state controlled media put out videos
and pictures of her living a normal life
how [ __ ] creepy is that dude what the
damn that's and that was because the wtp
the world tennessee they were willing to
pull out of china uh they they made a
statement saying that if she's not
accounted for and and is safe and sound
then we're willing to lose our business
in china which is worth like i think
yeah billions probably three billion
worth
but i
you know i would even go as far as like
well she needs to be i we need to see
her physically yeah well yeah that's
what they said yeah and then so they
materialized video and pictures is that
enough for them though were they like no
of course i know absolutely yeah
everybody's like yo this is not [ __ ]
you know this is clearly
under the control of state media where
where is her personal accounts right
like where why can't she speak for
herself why can't she come out
but
hey we gave you enough oh like
yeah so it's it just like it just shows
you man like how [ __ ] dangerous and
brazen and like crazy the chinese
communist party is so did the nba make
the right move well
well that's that's the criticism on
lebron right is that he doesn't have the
balls to speak out against all these
things going on in china i i would then
argue that um you know one person and
the entire state of hong kong is
different
right yeah yeah like
um at that point i'm pretty sure
uh the chinese government would want
hong kong over the nba it's like we'll
just copy and make our own nba yeah yeah
yeah well [ __ ] speaking of hong kong too
man i mean if i feel like the invasion
of taiwan is imminent too you know what
i mean hey you really think that's gonna
happen oh i think it's just a matter of
time but here's the thing even with the
hong kong situation there was a lot of
bold talk from other countries
right what happened though ultimately
none exactly so the communist chinese
communist party knows
y'all [ __ ] wanna talk [ __ ] but
nobody's gonna actually do [ __ ] so we're
gonna keep doing our [ __ ] and who's
gonna stop us yeah you know what i mean
and this was a long game that they
planned people think warfare is just
about guns and military nah digital
warfare economic warfare this has been a
long game for them they've been doing
this [ __ ] for 25 years against not only
us but anybody who might be an adversary
to them i just picture you disappearing
right now
they somehow got to you thank god i live
in america you know
you know all of their strategies bro you
know too much yeah i mean that's the
thing this is this is not a really a
mystery if you look into it
isn't it so funny though when uh people
who live in america right which despite
all the stuff that happens here it's a
pretty [ __ ] good country oh yeah yeah
absolutely in comparison to what's going
on outside right absolutely there's
people in in the country right now that
are hyper for communism oh they don't
it's a lot of young people yeah they
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about the retina house uh protests right
they were chanting uh some pro communist
chance i forgot the exact words but it
was just nonsense pure nonsense you know
what that is too privileged yeah that's
what that is dude there's people like
people who have really literally escaped
communism going what the [ __ ] are you
talking about you haven't lived under
communism you know what the [ __ ] you're
saying yeah it's just i i don't know man
it's that's [ __ ] crazy yeah so you
know like i i this one pixelated picture
of her see she's okay
[Laughter]
do you see right now it's like dude she
looks like prince's piece from mario in
the 1990's not like the video was like
with her eating with other people and
stuff like that i mean but it's so just
creepy man because you know this [ __ ] is
completely like directed okay now you
sit here
you pretend like you're eating there's a
gun next to her yeah exactly now smile
i said smile yeah you know that's the
worst thing i've ever
nobody bought this picture and video
evidence of her actually being okay and
and being safe and sound so i i don't
really know what's next now i think the
government is going to be like
ah we gave you enough we even did this
much we didn't even have to do this much
but we did so i i've heard a couple of
people who talked about um how china
wasn't like this before in the last like
10 years but it's been happening a lot
recently so
you see a lot of these like youtubers
who are
they're white and they lived in china
but they don't live there they live in
the states now and they do like all
these they kind of um do these language
channels where they speak chinese yeah
and you hear them and um i forgot who
told me the story but there was somebody
that they met
that um essentially spoke chinese it was
a white person
and um he was talking about how much he
loved chinese culture or whatever and he
goes oh do you still live there now and
he was saying that no he doesn't he goes
why he goes because the country is
different now it wasn't it wasn't like
the way it is before it's super
controlled like you don't know what's
going to happen he said that um he got
almost cornered and robbed multiple
times and he said it wasn't like that in
the first five years he lived there so
that's why he moved back to the states
he says like with government control
yeah like they
like him trying to create content all
the stuff is super scrutinized and he's
like i can't live there anymore so he
decided to move back five years ago no i
think i think there was always i mean
because look tenement square right
that's a prime example you know i'm
talking about him as a foreigner living
inside oh okay okay so okay i thought
you just talked about like the the kind
of the russian of the time we're talking
about micro in his personal experience
so he said like it's just
even for me as a foreigner who's trying
to experience life there like
that communist rule scares him he goes i
it wasn't like that before yeah and it's
you know it's obviously with these
stories it's getting worse and worse
yeah so we don't know what's going on
well yeah i mean but the thing is the
crazy thing is that [ __ ] ccp just
acts like freedom of speech doesn't
exist
you know maybe not for there right but
they act like that's the reality it's
like nah bro everybody else is talking
about it freely man they know what's
going on i think it's a major
philosophical difference like you can't
just say anything yeah like a different
thing yeah yeah yeah dude [ __ ] jack
ma disappearing is crazy yeah if they
can do that anybody right i haven't
heard it
[ __ ] from jack well he did reappear he
did reappear um but in a weird way yeah
yeah so you know he's not so public
anymore right yeah yeah exactly okay
guys
i swear it just shows you like it no
matter how wealthy how powerful you
think you are if you're not part of the
government
yeah they made jack chan turn on his son
you know
with the whole weed thing right yeah
because like he deserves it like holy
whole bunch of [ __ ] yeah
yeah they'll they'll tank you know
foreign movies because you criticize
this and that or whatever but jackie
chan i think is known to be like a china
sympathizer yeah and and like that's why
some hong kongese people like you see
him as a trader right yeah yeah really
don't like him but yeah like the
invasion of taiwan i feel like is gonna
happen
and
that's what scares me too i mean biden
said that he assists taiwan
right they say they say they say we'll
see when [ __ ] really hits the fan you
know that taiwan has been prepping
military you know doing military
exercises getting ready for this [ __ ]
china's
continually testing their [ __ ] but i
don't they don't stand a chance yeah
they don't stand their [ __ ] chance
man unless the milit like the us
military gets involved in a meaningful
way
like we're going to stand at your side
no matter what type [ __ ] ride or die
they're they're doomed
but think about that if the u.s steps in
like that that's not good news for man
for anybody yeah
us vs china going at it is not good for
anybody yeah just keep it a cold war man
yeah yeah exactly exactly but yeah man
they willing out over there bro i love
taiwan man i thought they taiwanese
people actually love japan because the
infrastructure that they set up over
there which is kind of crazy very
different from korean people
they're like [ __ ] japanese
history
japanese [ __ ] you kind of got different
history there bro well guys uh that
wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast uh genius brings every
thursdays and sundays until next year
january 1st we're going to go to once a
week you can catch ed at ed parkvp and
you can catch the other ad at ed2 secret
society s-r-s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-t
societies
s-o-c-i-e-t-y dot-com yes sir you guys
can catch the new back to basics drop we
haven't done a drop in a while because
of covet but this [ __ ] new line is oh
it's fire bro and people are loving it
too yeah we're loving it man loving it
loving it loving it so cop some gear
while you still can a lot of stuff is
going out super quick we still got some
of our stock from the previous lines uh
we need to move that out it's on super
discount uh we will see you all
next time
peace